hi there steve goffman here again
and um i want to stay on this theme of
studying grammar
which i referred to in my last video
and of course in the last video i
talked a bit about our spanish mini
stories but i wasn't able to show you
how i do it on
on
you know on our website at link so i
managed to get my movavi software to
work so i'm going to show you that
and i'm just going to briefly introduce
that to you now but you know one of the
big debates is how much do we need to
study grammar
when people think of learning languages
they think of studying grammar that
seems to be the first thing they think
of and then they say well i'm not very
good at languages because they couldn't
remember the grammar they couldn't you
know get things right and stuff like
that one thing that i do know is those
languages that i speak the best are the
ones where i have no sense of the
grammar
why do i speak them the best because i
have had more exposure to those
languages than to any other so there's
no question that the more exposure we
have the better we speak the less we
think of grammar the better we speak
however
to some extent the grammar can be a
shortcut because we can't invest you
know 20 000 hours into listening a
language we want to get there more
quickly can the grammar help us get
there more quickly and i think over the
next few videos i'm going to talk about
to what extent we mix in grammar um
to what extent we can just rely on on
listening and reading
uh and so in that sense i want to get to
these mini stories which are a form of
content that isn't isn't it's not
passionate
you know compelling interesting stuff
but they're not uninteresting ladies
little stories but they have a lot of
repetition so they help us get going
in the language
and
as i mentioned earlier i think that if
there are things grammatical structures
that we simply don't notice even after a
lot of exposure to the language that's
why it's occasionally a good idea to
read through a grammar book it's a good
idea in my view to save phrases and to
tag them and i'll show you resources
that can help you make sure you tag them
correctly and probably we need to
provide a little more help to people but
fundamentally it's going to be just you
know getting your nose into some reading
doing the listening exposure exposing
yourself to the language with a little
bit of a reminder through these other
ways that you increase your awareness of
the language you increase your awareness
of what's happening in the language but
it's not a matter of studying grammar
memorizing rules memorizing tables that
is only going to increase in my view
increase your um
self-doubt
and
decrease your ability to speak fluently
so with that as an introduction i want
to show you what i was doing in spanish
on our system at link and if you enjoy
these videos please subscribe and i look
forward to any feedback bye for now
the first story in this mini story
series in spanish
is
la historia de
story of miguel a cook who works in a
restaurant
these stories exist parallel the same
story exists in 20 languages
and it is our hope that people even
absolute beginners can start right in to
a story like this and start becoming
familiar with the language so i'm taking
the example of spanish some of you may
be new to spanish some of you may be
fluent in spanish but please bear with
me so as i look at this here's the first
sentence
what does this mean i don't know okay
miguel person all right i needn't look
that up
and it's now i've turned off the text of
speech because it comes on too loud but
this is a reflexive pronoun yeah i still
don't know what that means levanta lifts
yeah i still don't know what that means
click again and i've got the phrase
miguel wakes up aha miguel wakes up and
i have targeted at least tagged that as
reflex reflexive se levanta
raises himself miguel
so i've decided to save that as a phrase
okay miguel gets up and i'm getting
there don't forget that in these stories
you always have
the translation available available so
if you're having trouble saving words
one word at a time one phrase at a time
you can always
uh look up the translation by clicking
on this little translation tag
so next phrase allah says says what says
you look up says it's six
las says
what is lust says six o'clock why is
that las is the plural feminine so this
is very useful allah says first of all
as a phrase at six at six o'clock is a
time phrase i've tagged it for time
last refers to las auras we don't know
that right away but we have at least the
phrase allah says at six o'clock okay
miguel gets up at six o'clock then we
have the next phrase
manana is morning okay we also know
manano's tomorrow
and we have las mananas
every morning
the mornings a couple of choices there
but we see that las mananas las
we had la says las mananas it has to
agree similarly with todas todas
todas
now i intend to make a little video for
each of these simple stories to help
people understand notice what they're
seeing here they're seeing this
agreement of the adjective with las
mananas and we say the phrase and i say
this as an expression of time again just
like allah says because
later on i want to see all these
expressions of time
okay
and so i can go through we had a
reflexive
sort of phrase here miguel salevanta
here we have another one toma is to take
take a coffee
and he drinks coffee setoma now i also
saved this as a reflexive uh phrase and
i can go on doing the same val trabajo
en su
and
you know su trabaco a la siete media
here's another
time phrase siete is seven
but i click again add half past seven a
la siete emilia why don't i tag this as
a time expression
and
that way i can review these later on
de la manana
okay manana as we know his morning
listen to it again de la manana in the
morning there's another time expression
so that's one example as
now in our many stories the first 20
lessons are all in the present tense
but thereafter we introduce other tenses
we introduce the subjunctive and so you
may very well want to save examples of
the subjunctive examples of
past tense or anything that you're
having trouble with one thing i should
point out is that
in any of these
let's say we go to prepara
you can look up other dictionaries all
right if you look up other dictionaries
not only can you look for other
dictionaries but you can also look up
the conjugation
now i have to drag this in to my screen
here prepara okay here you have prepara
tells you where you are it's the third
person
and so you can see the conjugation if
you were in the imperfect or the future
or the conditional you would be able to
see that right away so one of the
advantages of working online is that you
can immediately
uh
you know find out more information like
like if we go to toma
all right takes we look up dictionary
we have two different uh we there's a
whole variety of dictionaries that you
can choose from but i find that this
conjugator is very useful so toma thomas
and you can look up the uh conjugation
so
i believe that with this kind of help
and uh even though the stories is a
little more difficult and but if you go
through the story
uh part a which is miguel escobinero
then we get this section b where
milevanto here miguel gets up and we
start to get used to the fact that
because it's levanto levantas levanta it
changes we don't need to say miguel here
melevanto i get out i get up he doesn't
say
levanto he says he doesn't i get up he
just says
and so we have the same vocabulary again
a second time but this time the story is
told by miguel and then finally we start
to get questions with again the same
vocabulary miguel cerebanta and we've
already gotten used to that phrase allah
says todas las mananas there's a
statement a question celebanta miguel
temprano and we see that in spanish they
use the upside down
interrogation mark but
because you have the answer here miguel
cerebanta allah says mananas and then
questions
and so we get a repetition three times
so once you've gone through this once
and then you listen
to
so you work this you listen to it
several times even though it's your
first lesson the vocabulary repeats you
say phrases you look up verbs
i think a person can get going in this
language
from this level and we're going to have
60 stories at least in each language and
we're going to help people to
save phrases and tag phrases and i think
this is going to be an interesting way
to learn
and if you then want to do the same
series of stories in italian or french
or russian or chinese you've already
been through it in one language and you
can easily transition to another
language so i hope that's helpful and
thanks for listening bye for now
[Music]
you